service along with these other
television providers giving you a front
row seat to democracy
next ukrainian professors examine the
ongoing tensions between russia and
ukraine the program on new approaches to
research and security in eurasia at
george washington university hosts this
conversation it's an hour and a half
well welcome everybody my name is henry
hale i'm professor of political science
and international affairs here at the
elliott school of international affairs
in the institute for
european russian eurasian studies at
george washington university and also
co-director of ponar's eurasia the
program on new approaches to research
and security
in eurasia and i'm very happy on behalf
of my colleagues to
welcome you to this panel on ukrainian
perspectives on current u.s russia
crisis
um
we have heard a lot of voices on the
crisis
and it struck us that one that we have
not often heard
has been the perspective of ukrainian
scholars we've heard
ukrainian people on the street ukrainian
government officials lots of american
voices lots of russian voices
but what we wanted to do here was to
present to you a variety of leading
voices from ukraine's own experts on
not only politics in ukraine but also
russia-ukrainian relations and broader
concepts that they research as part of
their
careers so um the speakers today will be
vladimir dubovic from odessa's mechnikov
national university sergey kudelia from
baylor university tatiana malyarenko
from the national addis a national
university of dessa law academy alexi
herron of the democratic initiatives
foundation and kiev mohillah academy and
oxana sheville from tufts university um
and again just before we go i will note
that the the program uh is uh sponsored
here by uh eurasia
and by uh iris the institute european
russian eurasian studies and its petra
uh program on ukraine uh at the elliott
school of international affairs here at
uh gw
and so want to thank everybody for that
um
we've asked each speaker to
lead off with about eight minutes of
comments to keep it fairly short we
anticipate lively discussion so
encourage you to present your uh
comments uh uh for the guest's reaction
and uh also to present questions you
might have for them in the chat as
moderator i will um
relay questions from the chat to the
speakers so um just as they're speaking
please feel free to pose your questions
and i look forward to what should be a
really stimulating discussion with a
interesting diversity of viewpoints
so uh we'll just go in the order in
which people are listed in the program
so our first speaker will be uh vladimir
dubovic from odessa's mechnikov national
university
oh thank you henry thank you for giving
us a voice ukrainian scholars on the
subject and i appreciate it very much so
well what is going on and that's a
question that's on our minds uh for a
long time now and uh for weeks and it's
not months and uh let's try to decipher
even though there is no clarity even yet
after many many weeks of guessing very
intensive analysis and overall analysis
still we're not quite sure what's going
on it is definitely a crisis uh you know
it's not really ukraine crisis but uh
much broader crisis it's just over
retraining crisis over ukraine perhaps
or as the title of this panel suggests
u.s ukraine russia but you can throw
belarus there you can throw natalie in
there so there are many players many
faces in many aspects of the crisis
um basically there are two ways of
explaining what russia is doing the one
is that they're preparing for invasion
and in that case of course it's also
very important to try to understand what
kind of invasion where when
and under what circumstances and is
there a way to actually prevent that
from happening or is it a big very
credible very costly uh very
systemically organized intimidation game
uh because what we've seen in the recent
weeks or even months actually you know
falls under both of those scenarios and
we can't tell we can't quite tell
uh it is uh something that's been uh
timing of it uh has also been puzzling
like why now why always suddenly this
sense of urgency in moscow auditorics
and and their statements uh why they
think that this needed to be decided
right right away there are many
explanations here uh starting from
perhaps something going on in kremlin
with syllabic with hawks taking upper
hand and moderates being sidelined
something going on here in ukraine
obviously when zolensky was seen for a
while by putin as a worthy uh
counterpart and maybe a softie where uh
with whom putin can actually achieve
something uh over ukraine but that
proves not to be the case and in fact
zelensky have done a number of uh things
including taking a bunch of pro-russian
tv stations off the air and actually
putting under house arrest mr medvedev
who is putting stop money in ukraine
uh that's one of the reasons of course
because i've seen an article in time
other day i think yesterday where the
author was actually suggesting that
probably a major reason behind what
putin is doing but i don't i don't think
he is arranging his friend victor
midwich i think it's much broader than
that
uh he probably also has something to do
with ukraine nato corporation which is
really going forward uh you know on in a
turbo speed and that troubles russia and
they actually say it out loud that uh
even without ukraine being member of
nato we are already seeing such a
tremendous
uh you know uh you kind of unprecedented
amount an extent of cooperation that
we're worried that ukraine would be de
facto member even without having a
membership if that uh pace continues
uh and then also perhaps there is
something was happening in black sea i
don't know with the presence of native
battleships here with uh spy uh planes
uh nato and american players flying
over ukraine with uh strategic bombers
flying not too far from from from
russian borders something here as well
what tipped uh putin over this red line
that he maintained this uh crazy
intensity and urgency we don't know yet
but what we're seeing is of course is
very alarming and what what uh really uh
interests us of course is uh there are
enough of rationality labs in terminal
because putin was primarily known always
as a rational player uh someone who is a
shrewd and cool technician but is he
still that player or is he someone who
got so passionate emotional who became
an idiolog with his pronouncements and
his articles about ukrainians and
russians being part of one people and so
on uh is he really trying to commemorate
the 30th anniversary of uh you know
dissolution of soviet union and the
100th anniversary of creation of soviet
union by some moves
that are designed to bring certain parts
of
lost territory back to russia
we don't know but uh we will probably
see on our ukrainian side what we're
seeing is that we're seeing a lot of
hybrid stress as well uh with it with a
threat of
explicit invasion uh uh we still also
suffer through a lot of hybrid threats
and there are many calls about schools
being mined and that's not just uh you
know sporadic episodes we're having
hundreds of calls in major ukrainian
cities about high schools being mined
and they have to be evacuated they've
been major cyber attack that put down
the websites of ukraine's ministries and
agencies uh there have been many other
things embassies of course started
evacuating few not too many but some uh
the airlines cut
some of their uh overnight stays uh here
in kiev and elsewhere in ukraine so it's
been a you know kind of tense situation
here but also uh there is uh i believe
there is some kind of disconnect in
terms of how ukrainians see the
ukrainian leadership and americans do
and you've noticed uh the other day the
conference the press conference with mr
zielinski when you don't claim the
threat and the next day there was a
security council meeting and the russian
representative there and the united
nations has actually quoted zylenski on
saying that
america is instigating the the whole
hoopla
and intensity and ukraine doesn't see a
real threat uh there are many reasons
and attempts to explain what's going on
where what are the reasons for the gap
uh one is that zerensky's actually saw a
lot of those escalations before
including one in the spring of last year
another one that we got used to it was a
huge uh you know amount of russian
troops next to our borders uh but uh
also the economy you know the economy
they say uh he tries to prevent panic
and because we're already seeing a major
capital flight from ukraine in recent
weeks
uh but also i'm afraid there is a
certain lack of trust between washington
and kiev's days which is troubling me
because uh it's exactly a situation
where where our position should be
watertight and yet there is probably a
lack of trust and that goes back to 2019
when zelinski was only starting to be
president and he faced
trump's blackmail and that's when he
learned that americans might actually be
playing some tricks and games and there
is a popular conspiracy theory and i'm
afraid probably
zolensky believes it himself that united
states have some kind of a game in mind
uh trying to
uh scare ukrainians
into some concessions uh you know
vis-a-vis russians i don't see any
evidence of that but that's a widespread
notion here in ukraine and before i
conclude to give the floor to the the
other speakers on our panel i would like
to say that on our ukrainian side also
it's very important that we have
this resilience in place and we're
trying we're doing our best of course in
some places there's more uh nerfs now
and more tension than others for
instance president zileski for some
reason mentioned kharkiv just
put figured it out that russians might
take he said or for instance we know
that odessa with this geostrategic
location of significance to russia is
also one of the uh you know probable uh
directions for assault if assault
actually takes place
uh it's also very important for for the
united message coming from ukrainian
leadership because one day we have
someone who's in charge of a national
defense and security council saying
we're out of means and the next day the
office of president says no no we're
actually not out of means so i i don't
think that's helpful on part of ukraine
and i think it's also the pr moment is
lacking uh there is not much of a work
that government does with the population
preparing for whatever comes you know
what uh different eventualities that
might happen in the coming weeks and
months there is not much work being done
maybe on some uh city levels like in
kiev where police does more of that but
here in odessa for instance i don't see
any preparations for any troubles for
any attack let alone attack but any any
difficulties and most finally i uh i'd
like to offer the opinion that uh on the
subject that some people say that putin
got himself up so high in a tree that he
couldn't climb down now i don't think so
i think that first of all for domestic
consumption he would easily present
himself as the winner but for
international uh audience he is also
presenting he might present himself as a
as a leader over our country which
grabbed attention for for many months
now it's a major show of force it's a
don't mess with us message which is
working uh they really miss the cold war
and now they are many steps closer to
this cold war because they really needed
this kind of limelight that they had for
40 or 45 years of the cold war and uh if
he de-escalates uh he'll be awarded
he'll be a hero i mean he'll be a peace
hero he'll be deserving a nobel peace
prize so i think that putin would
definitely if he chooses to escalate he
would find a certain trophies that he
can show
to domestic audience and also to the
people around the world that he's
achieved through this uh crisis thank
you
hey thank you very much felida our next
speaker is sergey kodelia of baylor
university
all right thank you uh henry thank you
merlin for organizing the panel
i'm glad to be part of it
and we've heard from multiple
speakers already the discussion
of the current crisis in the context of
russia of putin's motives of his
imperial ambitions of his goals and
relations with the west
and this is a valid approach
because obviously putin is
the only or the key decision maker in
russia so it's reasonable to focus on
him but this tells only part of the
story
and in my remarks i want to focus on the
other part of the story and that is on
ukraine
and let me primarily say or
formulate my thesis and that is that the
rising tensions on russian ukrainian
border are symptomatic of a breakdown of
diplomatic efforts to resolve the
conflict in donbas
why is donbass central to understanding
the current crisis well let me suggest
two main reasons
well first for russia the minsk
agreements offered the solution not only
for settling the conflict
but also for addressing broader security
concerns associated with ukraine's push
for nato membership
and we've heard over the last weeks
from russian diplomats multiple
expressions of concern that about the
possibility of ukraine being drawn into
nato or in closer cooperation military
cooperation with the west now how would
minsk agreement resolve this well it one
of the elements of the minsk agreement
is the autonomy for parts of donbass and
that autonomous status would give dembas
a stronger say
over ukraine's policy choices including
foreign policy and this would in fact
require ukraine to adopt neutrality or
risk a renewed armed conflict within its
borders now there is already a
significant demand popular demand for a
neutral status within ukraine over 40
percent according to the latest service
actually would support neutrality for
ukraine and bringing the rest of the bus
in would only make this support
overwhelming
hence as long as moscow saw any
prospects of implementing minsk it was
willing to abstain from seeking other
non-diplomatic means of preventing
ukraine's nato membership
secondly over the last eight years these
two self-proclaimed republics in denmark
turned into de facto enclaves of russia
over half a million people who lived
there received
russian citizens citizenship
which obviously gives moscow a formal
pretext to openly defend the region in
case there is a military pushback from
ukraine
at the same time we understand that
there is a low-intensity military
conflict that continues and has
continued for the last eight years in
the region
we see daily ceasefire violations we see
daily killing or weekly killing of
military personnel
some civilians are being killed as well
we see violations of the prior
agreements to withdraw troops and in
fact the heavy military equipment is
positioned on both sides of the contact
line
all of this creates favorable conditions
for the military escalation at any point
if full-scale russian invasion of
ukraine begins it would be triggered by
the intensified violence in donbas and
justified by the need to protect
russia's citizenship citizens there now
how did ukraine's diplomatic posture on
the bus change under zelinski and
vladimir just alluded to one of these
changes and that is an inherently
contradictory position of the ukrainian
authorities with regard to the minsk
agreements
in public statements to the
international audiences the ukrainian
authorities declared their commitment to
the fulfillment of the minsk agreements
for example just following the recent
meeting of the normandy four advisors
last week
in their joint declaration they said
that the miss agreements are the basis
of the work of the normandy format
at the same time in communication to the
domestic audience ukrainian officials
dismissed dismiss minsk agreements as
unworkable and dangerous
for example already this week the
secretary of the national security and
defense council alexei danilov stated
that the fulfillment of minsk agreements
would mean the destruction of the
country
these mutually exclusive statements sent
a very clear and strong signal to moscow
that ukraine no longer takes the
diplomatic track of conflict resolution
in dunbas seriously
moscow is then faced with two choices
either allow itself to be duped or take
action to bring ukraine back to a
negotiation table as we've seen in the
case of illovys or the balsa the most
compelling response from russia's
standpoint could only be military in
nature
secondly zelinski's position on several
key issues with regard to denbas has
become
even less flexible and more hardline
than that of poroshenko for example
zelensky dismisses the possibility of
direct talks with separatist leaders
which is the only mechanism for reaching
an agreement on the exact terms of the
settlement
zelinski dismisses the possibility of an
amnesty for separatist leaders and their
supporters which is the only way to
resolve security dilemma they would
the stage summon and demobilization
zelansky rejects any possibility of
giving parts of the bus an autonomous
status which is the main condition in
fact for the bus to become reintegrated
so the landscape's transformation that
happened over the last several uh months
from a peacemaker to a hardliner
could only be understood in the domestic
political context
since winning office he has been under
pressure from the nationalist right-wing
forces suspicious of his pro-russian
sympathies
this made zelinski realize early on that
any conciliatory moves in talks on
donbass could be used as a pretext for
another maidan revolution or for his
removal
as a result zelensky now finds that a
continued deadlock over donbass is much
more advantageous for him politically
than any diplomatic breakthroughs that
could come for him at a very high high
price
so the kremlin strategy of raising
tensions on ukrainian border represents
an attempt to raise the external costs
of further diplomatic deadlock
and an attempt to change zelinski's
political calculations
even the threat of the russian invasion
as we've seen in the last weeks imposes
significant economic costs on ukraine
ukrainian currency has depreciated
ukrainian foreign bonds have been in the
downward slide the crisis is also quite
damaging politically for zelinski just
several months ago the survey showed
that ukrainians no longer viewed donbass
conflict as the issue of primary concern
instead they were concerned with
corruption inflation rising utility
prices so economic issues but now
the bus is back and the sense of
insecurity is rising among ukrainians
and with it the understanding that
zelensky cannot
implement one of the key promises of his
electoral campaign
for the east it represents a betrayal of
trust for the west it represents for the
western ukraine it represents a sign of
weakness because only weak leadership
could make russian aggression possible
zelansky's performance as military
leader is also not quite compelling
altogether only a third of ukrainians
thought that zelansky could be a capable
commander-in-chief
and ukrainians preferred poroshenko to
the landscape the role of a
commander-in-chief by a ratio of three
to one
this is further reflected in the overall
popularity rankings recent opinion polls
put poroshenko's party ahead of the
landscape party in parliamentary race
with poroshenko and zelensky actually
now tied in the presidential opinion
polls
these economic and political costs may
be one of the main reasons for the
attempt by the ukrainian authorities to
downplay the likelihood of the russian
invasion
but ignoring the threat actually we
understand would not make it go away
there needs to be an open recognition of
the fundamental drivers behind the
tensions and the serious effort to
address them so let me leave you with
three main takeaways first the threat of
russian invasion
is meant to raise the cost of diplomatic
deadlock over than bus second the only
way the western leaders can dampen
tensions without making direct consensus
to putin is by influencing ukraine's
diplomatic posture on minsk agreements
and third a change in ukraine's
diplomatic posture needs to be followed
by substantive steps in men's
supplementation otherwise we are going
to see the escalatory dynamics renewed
again
thank you
hey thank you
our next speaker is tatiana meliarenko
of national university odessa law
academy
thank you very much i would also like to
continue on
a topic on ukrainian reaction on the
crisis
and also the presidency lens he told us
that the war will not happen it's very
useful to analyze the direction of
ukrainian society economy and leadership
on the crisis and predict how they will
react in the case of real war
according to the calculation made by
office of president zielenski ukrainian
economy lost about 12 billion dollars
during this month of information war
around russian aggression and ukraine
lost access to foreign foreign markets
and all but already in february march
ukraine must pay about 3 billion dollars
on its foreign and domestic doubts
in general over the uh last year's years
of ukrainian hybrid war against russia
the ukrainian economy lost about uh 150
billions it's about 20 percent of
ukrainian gdp and uh has not yet
reached its uh uh position of uh 2013.
generally what is the most dangerous in
economy that ukrainian seems to be is
entering the cycle of never-ending war
with russia
that ukrainian government told that we
have to prepare that the conflict and
hybrid war on maybe some escalation open
conflict will take place for long years
but at the same time ukrainian economy
cemented its resource cycle so today at
the expert of resources mostly
agricultural products and there are
natural resources on is there a major
position of ukrainian expert and china
russia and the european union are the
major ukrainian trade partners and the
rules of china is cementing and this
year china
update his historical record to be the
first ukrainian trade partner partner
with 70 billions of dollars
and again ukraine also depends on
money transfer from ukrainian labor
migrants who work abroad
and this year again this assam updated
his historical record it's about 15
billion dollars so all the countries the
situation this uh that the country has
to expect resources and it increase
military spending
but more important however is uh that
there is no understanding in ukraine
what kind of war
will wage ukraine against russia and you
create the statement of ukrainian
authorities and direction of reform
defense reform they propose they change
almost every day and they contradict
each other so the statement there is no
uh general line what we will do and what
kind of what we expect to wage
and the first ukrainian um
strategy of uh military strategy it uh
state that ukraine is not going to reach
military parity with russia again in the
line of escalation of current crisis
ukraine adopted the docker doctrine of
military national resistance according
to which all population both men and
women have to be mobilized to military
service but today the number of armed
forces
ukraine it's about
260 000 troops and national guards is 52
000
and the border guard national bodyguard
troops 53 000 and additional potential
additional
120 thousands policemen who train to do
some military exercise can be mobilized
under the army in total in total today
we have about half half of million
500 30 000 military personnel and the
military spending increased every year
front of 1.6 billion in 2013
to about 5 billion in
2022 however these funds are mostly paid
from
salaries and social uh guarantees for
personnel 80 percent and only 20 percent
for military equipment so in fact we
have large army land forces who are
not very good paid because um
average salary is between 300 uh us
dollars per month uh to one thousand
dollars for soldiers who certified the
first
front line in eastern ukraine and
there's not very surprisingly then that
uh young people uh do not want to to
join ukrainian army ukrainian army
enjoyed very high level of public trust
among population but as the lawyer is
not so popular however a few days ago
following the reaction of ukrainian
society and western partner president
zielinski signed a degree which
recommends to increase the size of
ukrainian army on another 100 000 troops
and the one more 1030 or 130 000 troops
will be recruited according to the law
on territorial cell defense
more uh
uh dungeons from the point of view
economy i would say that this a lot of
troops one house and thirty thousands
will be found from local budgets of
ukraine
but local budgets already finance
education and the health care so it will
be huge pressure on local bond budget so
if
reform proposed but the landscape will
be implemented
in the nearest future we will have about
700 000 troops of ukrainian army again
not very well paid and not very well
trained
and as minister of uh defense reznica
said he is ready to mobilize about two
million of reserves civilian people
torment force and the plan to organize a
three months training for them to
prepare them to meet a russian army on
the board
of course it
sounds like black humor but it's a
little bit remind the picture of second
world war when a weekly trade civilian
population met a german high tech army
on the board
so what should be done i will be sure
first
that uh ukrainian military doctrine
should be revised
and uh it should uh take into account
the hybrid character of war i was always
surprised why we wrote a hundred of uh
articles about russia hybrid word
doctrine
but now we are preparing to this second
world war style military invasion with
hundreds of tanks and millions of troops
so russian military doctrine is a
doctrine of symmetric war high-tech war
in which private military forces uh
psychological operations cyber attacks
took
serious place and ukraine should decide
for itself and there should uh did or
should should do the economic task to
calculate limited resources how they
should be spent for different priorities
what kind of army we need
what kind of threat we will likely need
and how our economy and society should
react on this situation and second but
also very important it's economic
dimension economic development and
democracy for many russian speakers and
ethnic russians who live in ukraine
ukraine is a choice because it's um
perspective and
it's a commitment to european values of
human rights and democracy
but if ukraine demonstrate the big state
institutions and corruptions and poverty
and the financial management and weak
human rights protection
the form
majority of people for russian speakers
for ethnical russian of course it will
not be reason to support russian birth
in the ukraine but it will be less
people who would uh like to protect such
a state
hey thank you very much tatyana our next
speaker is alexi haran who uh represents
the democratic initiatives foundation
and the kiev mahila academy
do we have alexi
if i was so thrilled to hear all others
that i muted myself
totally
okay so i prepared a
presentation based on the
uh pool
of democratic initiative foundation
which was uh
the polling was ended at on sorry on
december 22nd
but there are now there are
newer polls
but basically they confirm our
our main
our main
results and actually i am very thankful
to sergey kudela who nicely
summarize russian viewpoint
uh
why the crisis is happening so i'm
actually happy to demonstrate how
ukrainian population view it and because
we
ukraine ukrainian democracies so we may
find people with different views
definitely so
uh
the points of sergey was that
russia is to rebuff nato expansion to
prevent military push up from
ukraine to persuade ukrainian government
to fulfill minsky agreements which
ukrainian government doesn't want to
fulfill
uh
and also to provide special status for
the occupied territories and full
amnesty to
uh the militants which ukraine doesn't
want
by the way you pray
well so let me let me just demonstrate
what we have
okay so this is
the blue line
okay
the blue line is support to nato
this is
just a moment
oh sorry
uh this is
dramatic turn in 2014
and then you see the support of
basically because of russian reaction
because russia attacked non-bloc ukraine
so when russia is saying okay let's have
ukraine as non-bloc status we had
non-bloc status nevertheless it didn't
it didn't prevent us from aggression so
and then you see ups and downs in
support
of
nato but not very not huge actually the
support is basically
quite stable and ups and downs may be
explained
by the periods of tension and some
search of compromises so
now we see the increasing of support for
joining nato
because of russian concentration on
ukrainian voters so basically when
russia is saying you know nato don't
expand to ukraine it's so dangerous for
ukrainian the more russia has this drum
beating the more support for
uh nato in
ukraine now regarding uh
regarding the landscape in his
comparison with parashanka and other
things
so uh first of all zelensky as we know
he he was elected as a pacifist he
believed in compromises with putin his
idea was very simple we sit down and
talk and we will solve the issue
parashanka didn't want to solve the
issue i'm ready to solve it
and what we what we received zelinski
made very serious steps towards putin
including the so-called steinmeier
formula withdrawal of troops and other
things and did we reach a ceasefire no
putin continued to
shell ukrainians not only ukrainian
soldiers but also ukrainian civilians
again it's not in the interest of
ukrainian government to start a military
offensive into advance this simply would
be crazy ukrainians by the way doesn't
support it
ukrainians believe that compromises but
not at all so if we are talking for
example about amnesty ukrainians are not
ready to give amnesty to the leaders of
the separatist but basically to
uh to combatants
rank and file yeah this is possible you
know ukrainians do not sequestration for
those people who are
involved in
uh so-called state structures of the
so-called people's republics at the
middle and lower lab only about
so-called ministries and presidents and
other leaders of the so-called so-called
people's republic so
basically zelensky tried putin continued
his approach as a result the number of
those who believe that russia has
started the wind and bus you see
increased under the landscape still we
have about
how much it's about 16
of those who believe that that were
ukrainian government and oligarchs which
started war in ukraine yes we have these
people again we are democracy we have
freedoms we have tv and by the way we
have the presence of the opposition
pro-russian opposition on tv it is
continued so
uh now you see the next slide
again between different interpretations
isn't aggression of russia
assisted by local militants or it's a
civil war domestic conflict basically
red line you see the decline which
happened just in one year just in one
year again because of russia is
doing
now let's this is about consent
potential concessions from ukraine how
many ukrainians support it but
let me uh let me uh show you perhaps one
of the main issues
this is
cagl this is translation clumsy
translation of old law
in the english so certain areas of the
niskanen lugansk
oh danielson lugansk regions
which is official formulation in minsk
agreements
now you see how many ukrainians think
that
[Music]
that nothing
that this territories should be returned
uh to ukraine uh in the status that was
before 2014. you see basically that this
is not less than 50
54
now how many people believe
that these territories should get
autonomy from
ukraine
you see certain percent
basically the figure is
stable so this is not about yes this
provision of minsk agreements is not
popular at all
uh
can we say that
ukraine denounces minsk agreements
agreements no
because if we read minsk agreements uh
according to their logic not in russian
interpretation there is number one
number one is ceasefire numbers two is
withdrawal of uh heavy weapons exchange
of prisoners and so on and so forth and
only then there are political
uh political issues so basically we
cannot move towards political issues
which are really you know divisive
without implementing
uh security provisions but there's no
ceasefire in ukraine
since 2014.
again it's easy to reach
if there is a will of putin i'm quoting
mr hook
a swiss national who from osce
who was saying yes if you see the
clashes
again you see the periods when the
clashes are high
and you see zero violations of minsk
agreements which means it's very easy
to implement cs5 if there is a political
will
there is a ceasefire and again for
ukrainians we prefer peace why because
we are democracy because all our victims
they are on television
so it's not beneficial for us to lose
people for any ukrainian government
while for putin it's just a cannon
fodder
you know
it's not on television how many people
in the past are killed on russian
television how many militants are killed
and how many russians are um
are killed and finally let me
let me present you this is there is a
partial ban
on some russian channels not all we
still have russian channels in ukraine
in russian
but this is
attitude towards the ban of some russian
showbiz and movies
and you see definitely the trend so
redline the gains ban and green line is
in favor of the pen so the trends are
visible the difference is about 10
but the trends are visible finally
western reaction
by the way ukrainians are strongly
against direct talks
with putin more than 50 percent of
ukrainians are against direct talks with
putin but
to talk to putin in the presence of
international
mediators regarding uh regarding direct
negotiations with the leaders of
militants
this is not zelinski's invasion in
invention it was traditional approach to
uh of ukrainian democracy again they are
not independent players at all they are
not independent actors it's so at all
it's not even like in abrasia or
transmission you know fully controlled
by
russia criminals and
militants finally the western the
western reaction the western reaction is
belated
we are central to what we hear now for
what is done
but the only thing which may stop putin
is the strength of ukrainian army
so we have belated support supply of
arms to ukraine and sanctions and only
now after eight years of the war
the west is talking about potential
personal sanctions
against putin and what is important for
us is that
because there is a possibility of the
so-called limited military operation
it's very important recent american
statement that any incursion of russian
troops
uh would be considered as impression and
by the way there is a
sweeping annexation of uh creepy
creeping annexation i'm sorry my english
is not so good
i'm from older generations so creeping
annexation of the azov sea by russia and
we don't see any expansion of
sanctions finally we see a lot of people
who
call us to
understand putin concerns
we have a lot from the uh
left-wing lead intellectuals and from
the left forces in europe for me it was
always a surprise because i originally
in my use i was very left-wing
and i know what are the
basics of the left ideology this is
international support solidarity
defending
victims and defending democracy not
dictators and aggression and in this
i just wanted to have a
very very short test in this
audience do you know what was the reason
for creation of the first international
and i am stopping here do you know the
reason henry
what was the reason to create the first
international
i think we need to move on right at the
moment so uh okay so i will i will i
will answer
and the
reason for that was solidarity of
workers with polish uprising
against russian series in 1864
63 64. so i urge our i put this question
actually to the shadow cabin ministers
of the labor party they did let's yeah
sorry alexi we need to move on to the
next speaker please please but just
remember okay thank you okay thank you
very much um our final speaker is oksana
cheval of tufts university
um thank you henry for um for organizing
the panel and for inviting me to take
part um sort of the advantage of one
last that i you know
you can kind of engage with some of the
things that already said but of course
many things that i wanted to mention
were already well put by other speakers
so let me try to pick up on a few things
um um and um make a few points so i
would begin by saying that um i think
one of the issues that make the current
crisis very difficult to solve that we
essentially having and even to think
about we're essentially having several
interlocking pieces where we essentially
have three interlocking crises of u.s
russian relations nato russia relations
ukrainian russia relations and it's hard
to say um and there are conflicting
opinions out there how to prioritize
among these issues what is really
driving uh like what maybe is the one
the main one with simultaneous progress
um is possible so i think it is actually
very helpful and important to think of
what's going in and around ukraine as
far as having these three simultaneously
moving pieces ukrainian domestic
political dynamics realities and public
opinion and elite preferences
putin's russia's or ireland putin's
ultimate cost-benefit calculation and
really the main goals
and then western response to different
moves by russia and how that in turn
might change the calculus so i think all
of these three things work together so
i'm going to try to primarily focus on
the ukrainian and to some extent russian
rationale there um and then you know
there's time we can also talk about the
western response um so i'll start with
the overall russian goal and the thing
that really is important to keep in mind
what is really russia trying to achieve
um and i think um we should take putin
at his word that he does see ukrainian
and russian as essentially one people
ukraine is denied agency and the second
child putin wants to limit ukraine's
sovereignty so it is about nato but it's
not only about nato i think it goes more
to geopolitical orientation of ukraine
and ukraine's potential departure from
russians who hold sphere of influence i
think we saw this that it's not just
about nato going back to 2013 as he
already mentioned when aggression
started following euro maidan ukraine
was not a member of nato it was a mutual
country nato it was not even on the
agenda and kovish was negotiating
association and free trade agreements
with the eu and even that was
unacceptable to continue so we had the
trade war starting already in the fall
and then of course annexation of crimea
and um instigation of insurgency in
bombas um after um the victory of
euromaidan right so i want to sort of
circle a little bit back to what he was
saying because i totally agree with him
that i think minsk could be seen as a
potential solution quote unquote right
in other words for russia if it could
achieve its its objective of limiting
ukraine sovereignty through um ukraine
agreeing to russian interpretation of
minsk especially the special status that
would give de facto veto power to the
separatist territories and the proxy
leaders that russia has installed there
over ukrainian domestic and foreign
policy like that does accomplish putin's
objective but i think it is also
important to keep minced in this sort of
broader context in mind so minsk is not
just the settlement of some ukrainian
domestic dispute that certain
territories gets gets autonomy or you
know greater say in domestic affairs it
is really and this is how it perceived
in ukraine and i think this is why we
have seen essentially a stall on the
minsk implementation to russia's liking
um since
you know after these agreements were
signed um in the conditions that of
course were not advantageous to ukraine
right that it would essentially give
russia the same outcome right that it
could potentially achieve through
military invasion occupation overstroll
the government and have the rest to
agree right that ukraine rightfully
belongs um
in the russian sphere that's right so
yes means could be the tool you know the
objective or rather the way for putin to
accomplish what it seeks what he seeks
right but there is this broader context
um and you know potential normative and
foreign policy and all other questions
is this unacceptable for one country to
essentially do what it may to bring
another country into its sphere of
influence right through these messages
so um i would say just a couple of more
sayings um on ukrainian domestic
political realities and of this
likelihood of a full-scale invasion
there has been this disagreement right
openly when u.s was saying that invasion
is imminent and zawenski is saying you
know don't um
don't uh overestimate it and um
create potentially you know basically
don't talk about it as imminent i think
that actually makes sense because i
think ukrainian domestic political
realities are such that any
invasion of attempted occupation and
essentially attempt by putin to achieve
what he seeks which is control over
ukraine's foreign policy in particular
but he will broader kind of orientation
i think would be incredibly difficult to
achieve by force um i hope putin
realizes this of course we don't know
and i think what it goes to it goes to
this dramatic changes in ukrainian
public opinion that we'll achieve was
illustrating uh with his slides the
irony of it of course is that russia had
so much leverage over ukraine up until
2013 there was this reliably kind of
russia friendly electorate in the east
and the south there were a lot of elites
in ukraine who had all sorts of economic
and other dealings
have influence over the media and none
of these leverage that would argue
disappeared um after yankovic fell so
had russia not the next crimea it's more
likely than not
that um say in 2019 you know even if
pro-western you know prashankar
government could have been replaced by
even more russian president than zwinsky
and we had this sort of alternation of
ukrainian presidents through the 1990s a
pro-russian leader would get elected
invariably disappointed the electorate
then you know more pro-western one would
elect would get elected in turn and then
that would alternate i think that would
have continued but of course you know
we're now looking at a very different
domestic political landscape the rise in
support for nato is the the decline in
support for any kind of russia union and
then um you know over 50 percent of the
population who are saying that they
would resist any kind of russian
occupation um an attempted um
control over the country many of them
militarily um these numbers are also
quite actually high there is regional
difference but they're also substantial
in the east and the south now this is
not to say that these numbers are
somehow like give us exact percent of
people who would resist but it does make
i would argue any kind of attempt of um
overthrow of the lenski government in
installation of some kind of russian
puppet government that would then do
putin's bidding very very unrealistic
this government would have zero
legitimacy no domestic actor institution
group or public would support it so
really the only way this government
could rule is through the force of
russian arms behind it which would mean
sustained occupation right and this is
why i think um you know even you know
putin's calculus this is not a preferred
um scenario right if he could achieve
what he wants through ukraine agreeing
to his reading of the minsk agreement
that would probably satisfy him right so
i will just um add by saying um maybe
just a couple of words on the putin's
kind of post-benefit calculation we of
course don't know what's in putin's head
and unfortunately what russia does it
seems to pretty much depend on what
putin thinks but a few things i would
mention i mean one it seems like it's
actually quite worrying that putin
almost lives in his own bubble um or
preferred reality when it comes to
ukraine there is consistent denial and
he openly denied it for example at the
latest london meeting that this change
in public opinion that alex he was
illustrating is somehow real
the narrative that seems to be
constructed is that these preferences
are falsified
um either because you know people don't
really believe um
don't really say what they believe or
they're hiding that true pro-russian
preferences so this whole idea that
ukrainians and russians are somehow one
people so these opinions you know are
either coerced somehow or people are
basically afraid i mean putin says that
much so he essentially dismisses
um you know not only the public opinion
as it now stands but also russia's
obviously impact on this change in
public opinion this thing that creates
quite dangerous uh alternative reality
and really raises the question to what
extent is putin rational actor we don't
really know who he gets his information
from i was on the panel with russia
experts a few days ago and one of them
suggested this interesting idea that not
only the decision making circle is very
small but now i was called
even fewer people have access to putin
so he may be getting sort of you know
information
um
along the lines that you know these
ukrainian preferences are not really
real preferences and the pressure were
to be there militarily that would be
welcomed on the streets and so forth
right i mean again i'm not saying that's
the case but it's something you know to
think about
so finally i would just stand on the um
point just to say something about the
rest and response i think there is
really dilemma for putin between going
small and going big right in other words
if he goes small sort of more cyber
attacks maybe um even there has been
some talk about formally recognizing um
annexation like a formerly annexing the
territories of lnr and dnr or maybe even
going a little bit i don't know
capturing as a village or something
right and then there might be muffled
western response to this
yes he can maybe get away with it right
but it doesn't really achieve his
ultimate objective which again seems to
be certainly um have say over ukrainian
geopolitical course and foreign policy
decisions and ultimately sovereignty
right but then of course if you move big
to try to achieve these objectives not
only it would be incredibly costly as i
said it would require i think outright
occupation of the country for a
substantial period of time with
substantial number of force right
it also you know there is no longer
plausible deniability
and if the western sanctions and
condemnation and potential russian
ostracism of the international arena is
there then again he doesn't accomplish
his objective because not only he wants
to control ukraine i think he wants west
to recognize this as the new normal
right so i think again here it's very
important how the west uh would respond
maybe we'll get to talk about it in the
q a but i think looking at these three
pieces simultaneously ukrainian domestic
political process preferences and
changing these preferences that oxy
talked about putin's ultimate objective
and different ways to get at is
including through the minsk process that
this he talked about it and then how you
know what the how the best response
right might actually change putin's
calculation which in turn could also
influence the likelihood of further
regress selection so i went there thank
you very much
okay thank you oxana that's great
there's so much interesting food for
thought here
we already have a good number of
questions that have come to me in the
chat what uh i'm going to propose is
that i pose one question from the chat
to each of the speakers
and then we'll turn to each of the
speakers and i'd ask them to address the
question that they've gotten plus
any one other question that they would
especially like to comment on or if they
would like to respond to anything that
the other speakers have said but if you
could keep the comments brief ideally
three minutes maybe four minutes each
then we'll still have time for a good uh
second round um so the uh question for
uh vladia dubovek
comes from pascal siegel and that is uh
basically what would be the economic
implications of a long-term russian
campaign of intimidation
um for sergey um i'll actually give him
a couple here because he got a few
questions in the chat um one is from
sarah whitmore which asks uh
and she asks uh whether uh you said he
could substantiate your claim about
zielinski coming under pressure from
nationalist forces um like what what do
you mean um and there's a related
question from a ben adida mitchus who uh
asks about like who
where do you see any such renewed maidan
like you talked about against zielinski
coming from and whether that might be
supported by the west
for tatiana i posed kind of a general
question which comes up at least
implicit in a number of the questions
we've gotten which is
what are the prospects for
reconciliation between
the uh
self-declared
donetsk and luhansk people's republics
the ordlo the occupied regions and kiev
for alexi
maybe you could address this question
from natalia uh who asks uh what
ukrainian people think
uh about whether they're ready to fight
um are ukrainian are you ordinary
ukrainians um ready to take arms uh
should russia uh move in militarily
or they prefer to keep neutral and
finally for roxanna there's a question
from yaroslav
bilihinsky who asks about um you know to
what extent internal crisis within
russia
might be uh driving uh putin's actions
so let's just go back in the order that
um we began and again just to remind
people please try to take pride proud to
be very brief so we have time for a good
second round um so uh valodia the floor
is yours
sure a great question about the economic
implications of a long-term russian
intimidation well first of all the
russian intimidation has been ongoing
for four years now since 2014 so this is
just a new phase a new stage a new level
that we're seeing but one of the reasons
they're doing what they're doing in
donbass is uh to make ukraine bleed and
be disabilized and lose money a war
effort costs money obviously uh people
were trying to invest into ukraine will
think twice whether they want to invest
in a country where there is a de facto
war ongoing even though low intensity
doesn't matter uh so it's been ongoing
but now they're probably seeing that
ukraine is still standing on its two
feet and actually registering some uh
modest uh growth economic growth and
that's of course not okay if you want to
strangle ukraine and they're putting
their game on a new level so
uh they are
already tried blockading azov ports of
bergansk and mariupol as you know
they've already tried the crimea is
taken away obviously so now there is a
talk about the blockade of a black sea
coast
as one of the measures that might try
without even putting any troops on
ukrainian soil and in new places they
might blockate ports of odessa her son
make a life and that would be another
devastating blow to ukrainian economy
and the whole scare which is ongoing and
just increasing the crescendo this panic
of his hysteria is already costing us
tons of money so
uh it's hard situation economically but
uh one thing is uh good for us is that
to offset all these losses we're getting
this amazing massive support from
international community particular
countries groupings of countries uh for
instance the prime minister johnson was
here throughout the day uh a revelation
you know the global britain is really
interestingly enough and surprisingly
for us is working as a major uh uh ally
of ukraine these days so they're
offering something like two million uh
two million funds uh pounds uh uh to to
to i mean two billion pounds of course
uh to support ukraine uh infrastructure
and energy sector uh there's been a
support from european commission uh
there is a new fund of five countries us
uk and canada and switzerland and sweden
there was a major uh supply of funding
for ukrainian needs as well so that's
interesting because uh some of the
things that putin has produced with
regard to this intimidation is that
ukraine is now flushing the money all of
a sudden losing the money but also
getting a lot of financial support close
to what we always wanted to have a
martial plan for ukraine that is
basically what we're having right now
even without invasion thank you
okay thank you very much um so uh sergey
yes thanks for the questions um so
zelinski actually is a interesting
populist figure
um that manages to maintain uh contact
with his voters with his supporters
through direct appeals through video
tick tock etc
but who did not manage to develop
organizational capacity to mobilize his
supporters on the streets
his political party the servant of the
people is losing support it is a virtual
party it really
does not have any physical serious
presence uh in the regions
and those political forces that do have
a mobilizational advantage other
political forces that are associated
with the
right
or nationalist forces like poroshenkos
european solidarity
the azov group the national corpse uh
svoboda party etc
and um i would just refer uh you to my
memo which i published two years ago
which is called veto on war veto on
peace where i described the dynamics
that
led zelensky to basically give up on
some of his early promises for
reconciliation
under the pressure of a series of
rallies that were held under the slogan
no to capitulation
uh in 2019 in the fall and then in 2020
pride right before covet
the some of the largest rallies that
happened in kiev and in other cities of
ukraine were held organized by some of
the same forces that organized
euromaidan revolution
including petro poroshenko was an active
participant of course in those
and in these rallies there were direct
threats to zelinski that if he makes
good on some of the promises regarding
for example the implementation of
steinmeier formula
he would be removed from office and
there would be another a third maidan
and after that we've seen that
despite his earlier promises he gave up
on the promise regarding steinmeier
formula and the steinmeier formula is
not implemented it is not part of the
ukrainian law and uh still
uh he also gave up on other promises
that he made uh while uh in while he was
in the first months of his presidency
regarding the direct negotiations for
example amnesty and the autonomous
status all of this was reversed
and partially
one can argue partially that was why
putin following the normandy format when
he saw that zelensky is not willing to
follow up on his earlier promises was no
longer willing to organize any direct
talks or meetings with him
in that
format with two other foreign leaders
so
nationalist forces are still very strong
and you know that there is a
open criminal case against
petroporoshenko
and we've seen that right after the
poroshenko's return to ukraine
there have been relatively large
demonstrations in his support and his
political party is capable of mobilizing
their supporters from different regions
of ukraine when he returned to ukraine i
was in western ukraine in beef and many
of my colleagues and family members were
telling me that they were receiving
requests or invitations from the
poroshenko party to come to kiev and
participate in these kinds of rallies so
the nationalist forces still have a
strong mobilizational advantage and they
are a serious constraint on um
zelensky's actions
um
also i wanted to briefly uh talk about
the findings that uh oleg c shared with
us regarding the popular public opinion
and i certainly agree that the majority
of ukrainians are very s skeptical about
the implementation of the minsk
agreements and reject many provisions of
the minsk agreements and yes it is a
problem politically for zelinski and yes
it is one of the reasons why he is
reluctant to move ahead with the
implementation of minsk but we know from
multiple other examples of countries
that experience armed conflicts that
these types of talks negotiations are
very costly politically unpopular you
can look at the example of spain and the
talks with eta with
that where highland portland has were
kept in secret you can look at colombia
and see that the agreement with farc was
highly unpopular among colombians and
was actually rejected at the referendum
but the fact that these types of
agreements are unpopular is not the
reason
not to try or seek to implement or
negotiate on the terms of these
agreements and in fact i would welcome
if alexey believes that ukraine is a
democracy even though all political
scientists know that ukraine is not a
democracy it is at best it is at best a
partial democracy and if you look at the
freedom house rating ukraine was never
ranked as a democracy
it is a partial democracy some can argue
it's a competitive autography a hybrid
regime it's not a full democracy but if
if you believe that it's your support
democratic dialogue and and uh exchange
of ideas i think it would be great if we
uh debated the benefits and the merits
of the minsk agreements in public on
television but unfortunately these kinds
of debates are not happening on the
ukrainian television because people who
argue in favor of the minsk agreements
would be immediately
branded as russian stooges and traders
thank you
okay thank you sorry so um uh tatiana is
next
yes it's on your question about local
attitude in donetsk and lugansk of
course i don't have opinion pool to
illustrate my position but i can speak
on behalf of my friends and the
relatives who live there i would say
that for this eighth year of the
isolation they accept the status quo
and the more and more realize individual
strategies of adaptations to realities
so they apply for russian citizenship
they try to accommodate themselves in to
find job in russia on a local market and
the less and less they perceive ukraine
as their home country and even in talk
uh they almost speak about ukraine as a
foreign country you just say let us
alone we don't want to return to ukraine
i think this situation will continue in
the future
and i sometimes i'm very um
surprised that um i'm originally from
donetsk i had to say maybe someone don't
know i surprised that too much attention
is paid to minsk agreement in minsk too
for me it's
more and more useless
both as russia leverage on ukraine
alexa demonstrate public attitude to
minsk agreement and public attitude to
possible reintegration of these
territories and it's less less useful
for ukrainians themselves both
population and then yet can lugansk
majority of whom has a russian passport
or in the process of application in
russian pastor and the territory
destroyed by armed conflict so i believe
that in the few next few years the minsk
talks will be uh less less important in
boston ukrainian and russian politics
thank you
okay thank you tatyana so uh alexi haran
next is next
don't forget yourself yeah yeah thank
you thank you very much uh regarding the
uh
regarding pools
and regarding
just just a moment i was listening to my
colleagues and i lost
where can i demonstrate a share screen
okay
share screen
share screen sorry
sorry somehow i'm lost because i okay
but i i will tell
i will tell you is that i've sent and um
i've sent and
that link
to our research it's in ukrainian bits
much broadest and i present it to you
it's also with regional breakdown so you
may see the differences but you may see
that basically
even in the east and south there is a
plurality in support of general
all ukrainian trend definitely with with
regional differences so it's in
ukrainian somebody asked me about access
to
uh english language slide i'm ready to
send it so just send the general mail
from pawners to where i may send it and
i will resend it to you regarding
attitudes to war
yes
we had our polls our own polls and uh
the other polls they were mentioned yes
plurality of ukrainians would be ready
to fight
another portion will uh
will
support army by other means
meaning money volunteering work
donor blood how to say it
being a donor of a blood
uh for wounded and so on and so forth
some people uh
will choose the strategy i don't care so
it's well my strategy would be of
survival
okay about 20 which is also
understandable so this is
this is understandable let me elaborate
on a thesis actually about direct
negotiations
with the militants and how it can be
done
but first of all let me say i'm i'm
really you know
uh
striked by well not strike by the use of
term nationals
and what do you mean by nationalists if
you were talking about
it in academic terms so you know to lump
in nationalists
uh center right
party
conservative right sloboda party
far right azov
well
doesn't make
make you understand
what's going on because you may simply
say the patriots the people who are
ready to defend
the country and within them there would
be a lot of different ideologies from
left to the right
from left to the right and people of
different
ethnic origin as well
the examples of spain and colombia
is part of spain occupied by the other
country
sergey is part of colombia occupied by
other country
so again what we are talking
is that russia would like to represent
it as a civic conflict if there is a
civic conflict yes there is necessity to
talk
but if it's occupied by the foreign
power who just installed the puppets
uh
how could we negotiate that doesn't mean
that we cannot reach a compromise
uh again as i have said
uh
in minsk agreement there's no mention
about people people's republic no
mention at all so when we are talking
about certain districts
are law it and decentralization it means
for local communities so basically if at
some point because i agree with tanya
that it would be very very difficult you
know and we see a trend of russian
forceful prosperitization and the
changes
uh people are isolated from ukraine so i
by the way i have students from
the occupied parts who are speaking
ukrainians still they managed to know to
study ukrainian but definitely they feel
isolated in this region so basically
there is a possibility to move forward
with discussion and even for this region
to enjoy decentralization but not kind
of the parliaments of presidents of this
so-called republic but basically
decentralization meaning self-government
uh self-government
as
at the community at the community level
so again compromises are possible but in
order to reach you we need to fulfill
some security reasons zelensky will not
be able to talk about political
concessions if there's no security if
there are no gains we can which he can
present to the people finally about
freedom houses so he unfortunately you
are wrong because after the orange
revolution ukraine was recognized as a
free country unfortunately we didn't
survive in this capacity
but
[Music]
well not to say that it's democracy you
know it's very imperfect it's hybrid
regime we can call it as hybrid regime
but to call it competitive
authoritarianism
come on by the way today there was a
manifestation of kevin hill academy
at the cabinet of ministry of ukraine we
demanded resignation of minister
so
but this is another story but this is
example of civic activism how people are
not silent and how they're ready to put
demands and to defend academic freedoms
because basically it was against the
intrusion intervention of ministry of
education
oh i said ministry of education into the
electoral process within cave mohair
academy so today you may see on your tvs
how it happened and those creativeness
of students not only from kiev
against the minister thank you all right
thank you um next is uh oxana shuttle
thank you henry let me address the
question that was directly posed to me
and then maybe i'll just make one quick
comment on the minsk thing so the
internal crisis is potentially driving
uh putin's um
strategies in ukraine the short answer
is i don't think so because i think it
is very uncertain that which instance
something to gain domestically if
actually there is an escalation in the
conflict um there are there isn't much
even crimea was very different but this
sort of like massive support awareness
and resembling massive support for some
kind of armed military action against
ukraine is not really popular from what
we see in the russian uh you know polls
it can only become more unpopular if
actually um intervention were to happen
and like dead bodies begin to come home
kind of what is the kazoo's belly like
for what purpose is that exactly being
done and then i think if you sort of
keep going down that line of thinking i
mean if say there are massive sanctions
on the russian oligarchs that they're
not able to access their properties and
so forth in western countries right like
we may also begin to speculate that
there may be erosion of an elite support
right so i think if anything russian
domestic context may be one of the
breaks right that exists um on putin's
sort of thinking right and uh potential
action in ukraine so that's what i would
say for the um on the russian angle um
the massive politics angle and let me
just very quickly comment on this
discussion we've been having about um
kind of compromises uh implementation in
ukraine like if zolensky um you know
wanted to compromise and was prevented i
think sort of the unfortunate dynamic
there is that the more russia kind of
the more aggressively russia pushes
against ukraine right
and the more sort of the goal is really
control of the country right like the
veto of countries sovereign decision
making the less likely any president for
that matter would be to to compromise on
this so in a way like any sort of yes
main school register and i think if now
to reopen these negotiations and you
know concede on this fundamental you
know cross what ukraine considers red
lines which is essentially the special
status that would give these regions
atlanta
veto over uh ukrainian domestic foreign
policy i think it's very unlikely so
it's sort of ironically for russia kind
of the less the the
the
less aggressive it stands would be the
more likely actually some concrete
compromises on amnesty on potentially
you know some sort of electoral um
arrangements i don't like joint police
forces like all of these things like the
specific bits of the minsk agreement um
i think they would have been more likely
not less likely to be implemented um so
i would just sort of live with this um
and we can continue discussion there
this more time
thank you very much um we have a set of
questions now that i'll group in the
following way
um one on the west uh one on again on
this issue of what's driving russia
and then another one on how ukrainians
uh kind of the ukrainian political
establishment is reacting
so i what i would do is just to offer in
the final 10 minutes we have each
speaker
up to two minutes to respond to any of
these that you would like but hopefully
we can make sure we get all of the the
questions covered and to make any final
concluding remarks that you might want
to make um so the question on the west
is from uh martin and it is about um how
do you assess the level of unity of
western countries in this crisis
um the question on russian russian
drivers is from boris klauser which is
um would russia react in the same
aggressive way if it were not for nato
but for joining the eu
um and on ukraine's establishment the
questions are a little more detailed um
one is about you know whether you see
um you know the the zelinski and his
supporters reacting in a different way
to this crisis than they did to the
crisis that uh played out last spring
also with russian troop movements in
terms of um using it to push for greater
uh support for nato membership um and
then there's a question from eli cowell
about um how the ukrainian uh security
services the sbu the mbs are um
addressing counterintelligence threats
posed by russian escalation and actually
the previous question was from natalya
sevilla again um so let's just uh go
again in the order that we started and
again uh request that people take no
more than uh two minutes for their final
uh remarks uh so uh vladimir uh
that'll be hard but okay uh actually
we've seen a tremendous amount of unity
of the west we were surprised uh through
that week when uh russians were meeting
first was americans in geneva and then
brussels nato and the u came up with a
very strong position uh you know the 30
members of nato of just one position
critical of russia supporting of ukraine
that's a big deal i mean of course that
could change if russia indeed moves in
it moves in with some invasion that
could actually break a little bit the
west but what we've seen so far is
really interesting and there are so many
other initiatives i hope that that would
under would not undermine the unified
coherent position of the west but there
are for instance the way where triangle
was awakened uh then poland is speaking
to great britain and then the macron is
going to uh apparently to ukraine and
russia and then schultz coming to
washington so there are so many things
going on now apparently everyone in the
west is kind of awakened to this
necessity to to stop prussia and help
ukraine
and that might produce some disunity and
some little different plans that will be
competing between each other but so far
uh so far ukrainians are really pleased
to see that we are not thrown under the
bus that west actually is ready to stand
uh strong for us
okay terrific thank you um so uh
yes very briefly uh on the question of
uh ukrainian power ministries um
unfortunately
the sbu and the interior minister have
very little credibility um in ukraine uh
sbu specifically the security service is
uh led by
a very close associate of mr zielenski
who has been implicated in a number of
scandals and corruption scandals as well
it has no political uh it has no
independence from political interference
it is viewed as basically a lever of
political uh control that zelinski uses
in order to target his political
opponents
and um
there has been a very serious criticisms
of zelansky administration for resisting
the calls of the western governments to
actually reform the security service
there has been no reform of the security
service attempted under uh the
presidency of voladimerzelansky
a number of plots that uh uh
that
that's uh
have been revealed by zelinski
some of them actually just raise a lot
of eyebrows because they do not seem
very credible
and uh
unfortunately it doesn't seem like uh
the ukrainian security services are
prepared to seriously tackle the uh
possible counter
possible subversion efforts
by the russian agents i also have to
remind you that the
zelansk administration was seriously
damaged uh by the revelations from
bellingcat uh regarding uh the failure
of the operation to capture uh some of
the pro-russian agents who were
traveling from uh
who were supposed to travel from minsk
um to uh turkey um and they were
supposed to be captured uh by the
ukrainian and supposedly somebody leaked
this information and so bailing cat
revealed that some of these leakage
might have come from within the lansky's
circles
um finally i don't want to make a big
point out of it but i want to show uh
through the share of screen option the
democracy scores for ukraine for the
freedom house as you can see oleg c uh
democracy score for ukraine uh was never
below four points in the period after
the orange revolution uh it stagnated
during the euchanic presidency and it
deteriorated under the
um
under the uh yanukovych presidency and
currently uh uh currently ukraine is um
uh is ranked as a partly a free country
by the freedom house so it never really
reached the status of a fully democratic
state thank you
okay thank you um and uh now we'll turn
to tetiana and actually have one more
question come in that's directed at you
so let me just pose it which is from
mikhail philippa who asks whether you
could imagine a federal model uh
constitutional uh for ukraine that could
make uh donbass willing to stay within
ukraine as in the ukrainian federation
thank you i exactly wanted to pick this
question
i believe that afternoon status for
donetsk and lugansk oblast could be a
conflict prevention mechanism in the
short period between the end of year
ramadan revolution and the start of
guilty invasion when local elite and
daniel ghansk were powerful and when
they began with their new government
care about their power in daniels but
now the federalization it's absolutely
lost question i cannot imagine any
situation when ukrainian society and
local people in the netherlands gardens
and in ukraine control donbass could
agree for such option supposed to show
us we could say in russian that's not an
issue now by the way i could um i
recommend you to read uh my article for
block 50 shaders of federalism where
this idea was explained in detail
okay thank you very much tatiana so um
next is alexi haran
maybe unmute yeah yeah yeah i'm
following the discussion with such a
pleasure
uh so uh the idea of federalization
never had support of ukrainians maybe
very very close period after 1991 after
that
yes people were in favor of more
decentralization that's true so people
supported more decentralization but not
further realization
um
if
regarding oh sorry
i'm sorry i lost my uh
lost my mind thinking about the pools
uh okay so now regarding freedom house
sergey there are famous and very
simplified maps
of freedom in the world
green
uh
three colors green yellow and i believe
blue
so after you may see it and you may find
it from uh
on the web so in 2005 yes ukraine was
recognized as a free country but then
yes we are coming to there are problems
by the way i think that the progress
ukraine has made after europe
is not adequately assessed
by
uh
part of ukrainian intellectuals
and
also experts
who are going to criticize the problems
and we have a lot of problems as you
know but still we are free we have we
are making elections
and the vote of the people do
matter finally regarding the question
what would be russian reaction to
idea to the process of joining the eu
let me remind you what happened in 2013
ukrainians simply wanted to have a free
trade zone
with the free trade zone we had free
trade zone with russia and the cis we
wanted free trade zone with the eu and
what was putin reaction reaction of
putin was no you should join the customs
union
so basically any move of ukrainians
to become more independent
is faced by putin brutal
attacks unfortunately it's for rational
view but it's also about some irrational
views in his mind which were mentioned
in his
uh by by my colleagues and
and for putin ukrainian democracy
ukrainian democracy and effectiveness
thank you okay thank you and the last
two minutes are for uh oksana
um yes thank you henry um yeah i think
that the question that
alexey was just answering i wanted to
basically remind the person who asked
the question exactly the same thing so
when in 2013 like the origins of the
current crisis when the college begins
to negotiate association and free trade
agreement right and we see first the
trade war already in the fall
of 2013 and then of course you know the
consequences um after that so to me it
sort of raises the question right like
um i mean i think it i think it is
definitely the crisis for putin is more
than just about ukraine and when it
comes to ukraine it's more than just
about nato i think absolutely i would
agree with this and that i mean to me
raises the question kind of what would
satisfy putin like what options like do
we have moving forward and unfortunately
they're not great i mean the way i see
it i think there are two possibilities
kind of the bad and the terrible one the
terrible one of course would be that
putin decides to invade right and try to
accomplish his goal of establishing the
sphere of influence by force right and
the bad i mean maybe less terrible is
that we would see continuation of what
we see now right we may see the sort of
weapon flow i don't know for how long
that goes back to you know the spring
there was a messing with the troops then
there were the escalation now we again
see sort of amassing i think they do
have a way out of it because they keep
saying how it's just military training
and we're not preparing to attack so i
don't think the invasion is
predetermined right um but um so maybe i
learned was that henry like there was
this question was the landscaping
differently i don't think i caught it
quite maybe sorry if um somebody maybe
else wants to answer it yeah just there
was one last question about whether
zalenski has reacted differently to this
crisis than the one last spring
we have any takers we can have 30
seconds on this otherwise we should wrap
up
all right well maybe at this point we
should just go ahead and wrap up um
thank you uh i think maybe maybe here i
just would add that we seize the
uh this crisis is somehow different
because the level of hysteria raised by
putin
is really really high you know and we
don't know
what he may do what would happen next
because in spring for me it was
understandable that
i think the idea for putin was to
blackmail the west and then to retreat
and push north stream too
for me it was part of the gate now
really i don't understand what putin
wants what he wants to get
and how realistic he is
besides the fact that he is going to
crash ukraine ukrainian democracy
okay well on that sad note i think we're
going to have to wrap it up again thank
you to each of our speakers for a
fascinating uh discussion and we invite
each of you if you're interested to take
a look at the website uh ponar's
eurasia.org i just submitted circulated
the link uh in case you would like more
analysis including references to some of
the uh policy memos and other writings
that each of our scholars has presented
over the years on these topics um thank
you again to ponar's eurasia george
washington university and again to
everybody who attended today for uh this
event um we look forward to seeing you
at other events thank you very much
c-span is your unfiltered view of
government